c'est une tradition à lyon chaque 8
décembre la ville s'illumine la fête des
lumières existe depuis un siècle et demi
une célébration en hommage à la vierge
qui est partagée depuis longtemps par
toute la population benoît gadret et
philippe iv c'est comme cela depuis 1852
chaqu mi-décembre une longue procession
vers la colline de fourvière avec le
temps la montée aux lumières est devenue
une marche pour la paix
je viens chacun d eux le panchen
fusionner c'est une très belle fête pour
le départ c'est pour remercier la vierge
qui est sauvée de la tester les lyonnais
mais contrairement à la légende la fête
n'a rien à voir avec la peste mais avec
la célébration de la nouvelle vierge de
fourvière le 8 décembre 1852
avec le temps cette fête religieuse est
devenu populaire des dizaines de
milliers de personnes descendent dans
les rues du vieux lyon ça représente une
occasion pour sortir et pour
la tradition veut que l'on en sait
balcon de bougies et que l'on dépose un
message d'amour dans ces petites
lanternes flottante qui toute la nuit
vogueront sur la somme
cité des lumières à lyon les têtes hier
soir avec ce spectacle sur la place
saint jean le soleil avait rendez vous
avec la lune
entre laurence piquet dans quelques
instants